I want you to think back to when earlier
this week we introduced this idea of
integration and it's this big new
category in fact we're going to sort of
spend the next
well not like twelve months nine months
wrapping our heads how around how we're
going to use this object but being weave
like we've just introduced it we're like
okay it's a new thing you know what
derivatives are and now we know what
integrals are there's going to be a
whole lot of thinking that we're gonna
have to just try and understand what are
these objects how do they behave the way
that I would compare this to is does
anyone know what the Large Hadron
Collider is has anyone heard of that
object before get a show of hands
because it's awesome nodding but not
much yeah very small No okay hands out
so the Large Hadron Collider is this
huge structure it cost billions
I don't know trillions of dollars to
create it's in Europe it's underground
it's this big circular correct me if I'm
wrong people who actually know roughly
circular track where they take two
protons and they use magnets I think it
is like really big magnets to accelerate
these protons to like ninety nine point
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine I think it is percent the
speed of light so they're really really
fast and then they collide and when they
collide they break apart too all of
these little pieces and earlier how long
ago was it when we were doing this
they're basically simulating what
happens at the Big Bang
well what happened at the Big Bang that
collision that incredible energy and
they discovered a new particle it's
called the Higgs boson and it's kind of
analogous to what we did here we
discovered this new object this integral
and we want to understand well now that
we know this thing exists what could it
do right so I'm going to talk you
through a bunch of properties you will
find pretty much all of these in your
textbook but when I look at them when I
first learned them I kind of found them
to be algebraic super so I've kind of
given a name to every single one of
these and the name is not there to be
like another thing to remember I hope it
just helps you understand what these
things mean okay so the first name the
first property is called sign and we
introduced this one before so I'm going
to write it in algebraic form so that
you can see the idea that we expressed
earlier the simple idea is that the
integral from A to B of F with respect
to X
remember what we're doing here we're
adding up rectangles with this height
and this width okay
earlier we said it's just area it's just
the area under the curve the area
bounded here and there but then we
learned when we tried to integrate
something like this we learned that the
idea of area covered by integral is a
little more nuanced right in fact do you
remember what was the area the integral
rather that we calculated when we did
this one we found it to be zero which
was sort of weird because it looks like
it's bigger than zero
but the issue is that you've got not
only an area above the x-axis you also
have an area beneath the x-axis and
integrals treat them differently so to
distinguish between this idea we say
it's more than just area we call it a
signed area okay it's a side area so
what this means is that I can have such
a thing as negative areas doesn't make
sense just in the context of measurement
by the concepts of integration it has to
be how do you work out what the side
area is well there are two parts there
are parts above and their parts below
right so what we do is we say you add
the areas above the x-axis those are all
positive
that's fine and then you subtract all
the areas that are below the x-axis
that's it now you can see here for
example if you looked at our example
over here right this area down here if
we think about that in classical terms
it's just like do do your base to your
height and you'll find out some value
but when it comes to an integral we have
to regard that as negative right so
since that's negative that's how we
actually subtract it right how'd that
means there's a double negative in there
so just watch out now sometimes you'll
see instead of saying Arab areas above
and areas below you'll see absolute
value signs appear in here some
textbooks use that you might hear that
from tutor or something like that that's
fine it's correct but I try to avoid
using absolute value signs because often
students use it in place of
understanding what is going on they just
say I don't know it area is supposed to
be positive so just pop absolute value
signs around it often you get the right
number at the end but you don't know why
it is what it is so it's because as I
said your assigned area that you can
have areas above is below you treat them
differently okay
all right the next property is actually
kind of a double-barreled property and
it has to do with symmetry okay so what
I want to think about is when you
integrate and your boundaries your upper
and lower boundaries are symmetrical
yeah thank you yeah all right I'll take
a seat they're like super late and
you've missed all this legwork I'm gonna
make you carry things outside just for
the sake of doing whatever else did if
you have an integral and its boundaries
are not just some random a to be
whatever right if there are an opposite
sides of the x-axis so for example from
negative 3 to 3 from negative 100 to 100
so you have symmetrical boundaries okay
I can work out easily what the area will
be if the function itself also has some
kind of symmetry to it okay so let me
say that again if you have symmetrical
boundaries and if your function that
you're integrating also has some kind of
symmetry then depending on the kind of
symmetry it has you end up with
something very simple okay
so for instance let's consider if it was
an odd function if it was an odd
function you're going to have a
situation somewhat like this right in
fact this is the kind of situation you
might have so I've just turned that line
into an odd function okay what does it
mean to be an odd function it's got what
kind of symmetry when you yeah when you
rotate and you rotate or you can say
across the line y equals x right so
because you've got an odd function this
positive area over here has to be
exactly the same as the negative area
does that make sense but positive or
negative what are they going to equal to
zero so if you have an odd function then
if you do symmetrical boundaries you
just get zero the parts on the left hand
side the parts on the right hand side is
canceled okay on the other hand though
if you have an even function okay so
let's just draw a little quick diagram
underneath here maybe beside we've got
some space you give me an even function
any even function y equals x squared
it's the classic example of an even
function okay so if we have some kind of
symmetrical boundaries here let's put a
over here so there's part of an area
that would mean negative A's on the
opposite side like this okay now what
I'm looking for is a shortcut a shortcut
that takes advantage of the symmetry
that's kind of built into this and the
symmetry that we put into our boundaries
so what might be a nice easy way that we
could evaluate this area have a look at
it what kind of symmetry does this have
again it's not rotational symmetry it's
it's reflectional symmetry right which
means that this shape over here should
be exactly the same as this one over
here just does that make sense so I
don't have to work this out twice I can
just work out one of them and then say
well you've got two of those same areas
right so I'm going to say there's two
what's off now it's a new integral it's
a new integral what
is one of these for example see this one
over here what integral would Express
that area just on the right head side
how would you state it the integral from
where we start zero you and that a it's
still the same ending point and it's
still the same function now you might
think well it's a bit funny like it's an
integral over here and it's an integral
over here what was the point what was
the advantage will you tell me have a
think about this think about what you
know about the process of integration
this is a good example because unlike
say that one over there which you could
just worked out with like the area of a
triangle there's no there's a formula
for the area of whatever whatever on
earth that shape is called right so you
know you've got two ways to evaluate an
integral once the area formula what's
the other way you're going to use the
start of the pig think think think
you're going to use the primitive
function right you're going to say well
if that's F I will find the primitive of
F F prime capital F right and then I'll
evaluate it at this boundary in this
boundary can you see why I would like to
have zero like when we're testing at
stationary points you like try zero when
you're doing polynomials try zero
because it's easy to deal with
right so that's why I like putting in 0
I like that boundary better than these
boundaries that make sense